first of all thank you so much for
taking time
to come and visit here really
thank you time is precious they're happy
you now elaine you just were here
visiting thank you so much and i did get
to do the butt shimmy with you
we did virtually we felt the love we did
it i still can't get that virtual
like a frame up perfectly but
um you have every media outlet that
you've tapped into
you're an incredible writer you have a
best-selling book i mean
how is this as a platform for you well
this
is an incredible opportunity to be
amongst these women every single day for
us to have
this bond that is kind of instant and it
feels built in and
this family feels built in it's just an
extraordinary dream
like dream job come true um and i think
you know
in this moment of real division in our
country
to for us to be bridge builders every
single day is really
really important and special and i don't
take it for granted
and we have fun too by the way i have to
tell you these women keep me
laughing i'm crying my eyelashes off
half the time on the commercial break
they're just
the best that's cause you're naughty
i'm a little nuts she's not lying she's
not lying i think that we're all blessed
to have a platform
because that's what this is we have a
platform every day
to be ourselves to talk about what's
going on
and it to do it with a
whole group of great women it's like a
gift
and drew i tried to do this on my own
and it's the toughest gig in the world
people don't realize
how hard it is to do it on your own so i
bow down to you seriously but doing it
on your own
well i mean first of all you've been
such a success
in so many uh areas and a pioneer i mean
that let's you know the osborne's also
was like
hadn't really been done and i was
married to tom green and i love that i
thought he
kicked off like a new genre like you
can't
do that on television or like you know
candid camera
and you really were you know at the
forefront of like a complete
societal cultural generational shift and
i've seen you
tackle so many things and then cheryl
i've really been comforted by the things
you've said because
i like to be funny and go for it and get
a laugh or go for the joke
and you know when you're riding crickets
on tumbleweeds
that's a little more difficult and
you're a real comedian
i mean do you feel like
that some authenticity has like seeped
in because you can't go for the funny
or are you like still excited for that
audience to come back
what has been the shift and change for
you well
we still have the audience it's the
cameraman instagram
it's everybody on the floor it's the
floor managers the stage managers all
the producers
but it's also these ladies right here if
i can't make these five broads
these four and i'm really not doing my
job
and i really like when sharon spits out
whatever's in her cup
so i've done it and any time carrie anne
kicks her heels up to show her underwear
what that is
i love that amanda and elaine they're
trying to hold it in and they can't
um and carry and i bet you do like
dance around i had no idea that you were
a backup dancer
for madonna i freaked out learning that
i'm going straight to my like
inner madonna freak out belly girl
that was a long time ago and back then i
used to not wear clothes and i had no
hair
but yeah it was a lot of fun i heard she
made you shave it like she was like if
you want to be on this tour you'll shave
that head
she did she lined all the dancers up and
the final question was you guys are
doing really well
um but will you shave your head bald and
i was like for you
absolutely yeah of course you don't pass
with that
well speaking of great women i also
loved reading about your aunties and how
much like
female community meant to you growing up
and what a perfect fit a show like
this yeah you know what female community
is as we all know is
so important being on this show is like
basically the way i was grown up i was
grown up with strong women
always giving advice like and that's
what we do here we all
share our stories when we have problems
like when we've had a bad show or a show
that we didn't think we did well
we reach out to each other we get
feedback when we're going through our
own personal problems
what's amazing is we have this built-in
community and
of resources that really helps and on
all aspects and
it's just so beautiful to share it
online for those people out at home that
maybe don't know what a girl group is
like to have
girlfriends we can be their girlfriends
and we also encourage them to show them
how to be good girlfriends you listen
you listen to each other
and you support each other even when you
have different points of views that's
right that's right
well i have really loved um
trying to get to know you amanda through
everything that you've put out there
especially
in the last year you seem like
a person who not only is so strong
and has been someone that we've watched
go through
a journey and yet you've opened yourself
up and extended yourself in ways you
seem like the nicest
most loving respectful spiritual
incredible person who i'm so glad that
you found yourself in this community of
amazing
strong women i can't think of anyone who
deserves that community more than you do
oh thank you so much it's so nice to
meet you i'm such a big fan of yours um
but no you you did say it exactly right
drew i feel
so lucky to be here um to get to come to
work every day to have something to do
but not only that um to have this family
is
is just means the world to me really
really does i
try to be a light in in the world um
and and those are my daily goals and and
uh
so that means the world to me and and i
just try to surround
myself with good people because i think
that's a good thing to try to do
and um and to then be a good person
so thank you for saying that well it's
so
evident
[Music]
you